what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the goddess Elizabeth and
how strong she is this video was
suggested by a bunch of you guys and
with what happened in Chapter 315 it
seems like the perfect time to make this
video make sure to smash that like
button for more seven deadly sins videos
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss any new seven deadly sins videos as
always leave suggestions for other
videos you would like to see in the
comments for even more some of the
licensed content conversations and
crucial updates follow us on instagram
at anime uproar keep in mind there will
be manga spoilers in this video as
always to get a sense of Elizabeth's
power we're going to be looking at all
of the evidence available to us in the
manga at first elizabeth Leonys seemed
weak her power level at one point was
measured at 1925 she scored a 1700 magic
e 5 in strength and a 220 in spirit it
seemed like the much stronger Melly Otis
was always saving her we kept getting
new power levels for Melly Otis his
highest measured power level was 140 mm
but he's gotten even stronger since then
in contrast Elisabeth didn't get a bunch
of update and power levels however as
the series goes on we do get more and
more clues that Elizabeth is way more
powerful than her first measured power
level would lead us to believe neared
the end of the first season Elizabeth
awakens to her goddess powers before
this without realizing it she had helped
heal her dad her sister Mellie Otis and
a doctor but it is only after the
goddess mark appears in her right eye
that we start to get a sense of how
powerful Elizabeth is the aura around
her so powerful that we even see the
outline of goddess wings
King can't believe how powerful she's
become that her energy field even
overpowers Hendrickson's attack that
threatened the lives of all of the
wounded fighters present including the
sins her magic envelopes the entire
Capitol and heals countless people some
who were on the brink of death after
this Elizabeth notices that Hawk still
appears to be dead and she faints in
tamela's arms so we don't get to see
more of her at that time still though in
one very impressive moment she could
stop
since strong attack hurt him and he'll
everyone else in the capital who wasn't
already dead
there's only because Elizabeth heals
them all that Mellie Otis and the others
are able to execute a plan that defeats
Hendrickson so as early as season one
Elizabeth proves that she is strong
enough to play a vital role in the
defeat of a powerful enemy eventually we
find out where Elizabeth gets all her
power Elizabeth is so powerful because
she is the hundred and seventh
reincarnation of the goddess Elizabeth
in her first life Elizabeth confronted
the Endura version of Derry areum won't
speed any demon was a power level over
fifty thousand and offers up six of
their seven hearts can become an enduro
Endura are considered to be the ultimate
evil form and they're extremely
overpowered the Endura have no problem
overpowering the Archangels Tarmey else
army and even Lew Rochelle who at least
has a power level of two hundred one
thousand however Elizabeth is powerful
enough to stop them she doesn't even
need to fight with them her magic is
powerful enough to transform Derry airy
and won't speed back to normal although
she does get some added support from
Tarmey Lance Armijo still the fact that
Elizabeth could stop these in Dara even
when someone with a power level of at
least 200 1000 couldn't speaks to
Elizabeth's own power by the time they
fight molasse killer Elizabeth has the
goddess sign in both eyes she's able to
help free a possessed the Anne and she
is able to heal bond and neutralize
Velazquez deadly poison in an instant in
the end it's Elizabeth's ability
tranquilized that turns will ask EULA
the commandment of faith into a harmless
snake again by cleansing her of the
miasma she absorbed in the demon world
up to this point we mostly seen
Elizabeth use healing spells or
cleansing spells in battle however she
does have impressive offensive attacks
too when assault mode may leotis wants
to become the demon king
Elizabeth decides to stop him with the
help of the seven deadly sins
Meli Otis is not about to let her leave
he has just recently completely
overpowered zelgius Esther OSA and
Cusack at the same time without breaking
a sweat it would seem like Elizabeth has
no chance of escaping
however she uses a powerful attack that
knocks smelly Otis out and gives her
enough time to escape with this attack
Elizabeth proves her offensive
capabilities
are no less impressive than her healing
abilities later Maya lets us know that
the goddess Elizabeth was on par with
Mellie Otis in regards to power as
warriors they were on the same level at
first I didn't read too much into this
probably because Elizabeth seemed to be
healing and cleansing most of the time
rather than using offensive magic she
didn't do much against eldress and the
original demon but she didn't need to
because king with full grown wings and
mile with sunshine were more than strong
enough to handle them when the demon
king takes over Mellie Otis's body the
others attacked but Elizabeth doesn't
then Vaughn arrives and we never get to
really see what Elizabeth is fully
capable of she does enter melee Otis's
mine with the other sins so she can help
boost his morale and give him the
emotional strength he needs to defeat
the demon king from the inside but she
doesn't play a big role in the fighting
itself her arc along with Merlin's
perfect cube and Kings Paul and garden
don't appear to be strong enough to hold
the demon king inside everyone
eventually helps to defeat the demon
king but bond definitely plays a major
role in that fight so up to that point
in the manga Elizabeth didn't seem that
strong compared to Mellie Otis and bond
I assume that she didn't do much against
the demon king because she couldn't but
now it appears like I was mistaken
perhaps if bond didn't show up we would
have seen me much more powerful
Elizabeth than we saw up to that point
but bond did show up and he was strong
enough so that Elizabeth wasn't really
necessary for the fight when we look at
the most recent events in the manga it
seems like what Miles said about
Elizabeth being on par with veliotis
before wasn't as absurd as it may have
sounded at first Elizabeth says she
wants to come with Mellie Otis when he's
going to fight demon king zelgius he
agrees but he doesn't just ask her to
come with him so he can protect her he
asks her to fight alongside him he
believes that she can fight at his side
as an equal at the fight demon king
zelgius grabs Elizabeth he tells Mellie
Otis that dragging this burden s
extra baggage along was a mistake
referring to Elizabeth he assumes that
he was just trying to protect her from
the curse then Elizabeth laughs at the
idea that the demon king will hold her
hostage
Elizabeth confidently looks at the demon
king and tells him that she hasn't come
to be a burden on Mellie Otis she's come
to defeat
the demon king she proceeds to send the
demon king flying with her power by the
end of her attack the demon king is
wounded bloody while Elizabeth is
completely unharmed
Mele Otis says if you underestimate her
you'll end up in a world of pain just
like I did a long time ago as the demon
king I'm sure you know what they used to
call Elizabeth in the underworld right
blood-stained alley and quote what an
epic transformation this was Elizabeth
went from being a constant damsel in
distress in the beginning of the series
and has become someone who can overpower
the demon king with her attack
Meli otis suggests that he ended up in a
world of pain himself when he
underestimated her in the past and he
gives us another interesting fact the
demon world used to refer to Elizabeth
as blood-stained Ali this implies that
like Miley Otis Elizabeth wasn't always
the person she is today most of the time
now she's a kind soul who heals and
cleanses people for their own good
however it appears like she was able to
be quite brutal in the past she spilled
a lot of demon blood before she changed
her ways it seems like she could always
use such powerful attacks she just never
did because she didn't want to hurt
people but now against demon king she is
ready to go all-out she is right to be
as merciless as she probably was before
she met Mellie Otis obviously the demon
king should have more up his sleeves and
he was probably caught off guard too but
it does seem like he is infuriated and
concerned about Elizabeth's great power
my prediction is that it will take the
combined effort of Elizabeth and Mellie
Otis to finally defeat the demon king
wants it for all Elizabeth has clearly
been holding back until now but no more
we will see Elizabeth at full power 100%
serious
and it seems that what Miles said was
not far from the mark because she's not
holding back and she's fighting for
someone she loves she might just be on
par with Mellie Otis's power we saw the
huge transformation that Elaine
underwent for bond and how much more
powerful she became and since the
goddess Elizabeth has a much higher base
power level we should expect her to be
able to grow insane amounts for Mellie
Otis not even mile with sunshine or king
with full-grown wings could do anything
against the demon king when he was in
Mellie Otis's body and yet Elizabeth
just straight-up in
barest him with her Opie attack
Elizabeth's evolution is a single most
dramatic power transformation that we've
seen in the series she's gone from being
one of the weakest characters to being
one of the strongest she went from being
one of the most easily frightened and
shy characters to being one of the most
confident and bold characters I firstly
can't wait to see what happens next well
let me know what you think about
Elizabeth transformation and her newly
revealed power did you actually see it
coming or did you think that Elizabeth
feels more of a powerful healer than a
fighter like I did and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell for more some of that lee sin's
videos if you enjoyed this video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know
for even more seven deadly sins content
falls on instagram at anime uproar a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make these videos
possible I especially want to thank our
pro tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man nothing but a
fan and Jason Wilson and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans baby Rey a seventeen ffvp Steven
and Greta a Lola autumn Maddy Mac 239
and Michael Calderon if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon comm anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these epic people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you